NANCY WEISS MALKIEL: "Keep
the damned women out."
[LOCKING SOUND]
The Struggle for Coeducation.
I'm Nancy Weiss Malkiel.
When I was finishing up
as dean, President Tilghman
asked me if I would be
interested in writing a history
of coeducation at Princeton.
And I said, sure.
After all, I had experienced
all of coeducation
at Princeton from
the very beginning,
in terms of chronology and
being here as a faculty member.
I had had responsibility
for the education of women
as well as the education of men.
And as an alumna and
trustee of Smith,
I was very interested
in women's education
from that point of view.
I made up a timeline
of who went co-ed when.
I had a hard enough time keeping
this straight for myself,
and I figured that other
people would be even less
familiar with it than I would.
And I saw this huge bunching
between 1969 and '74,
and said to myself, that's a
much more interesting question.
Why did all of these
schools go co-ed all at once
in this very short
space of time?
So I thought, I really need
to locate Princeton much more
firmly in the context of
this much broader movement
toward coeducation, which is
how I came to write the book.
It's a quote from a
Dartmouth alumnus writing
to the board of trustees
as Dartmouth was beginning
to discuss coeducation.
And he wrote, "For God's
sake, for Dartmouth's sake,
and for everyone's sake,
keep the damned women out."
It's a book about how very
traditional, very conservative,
very elite, very old colleges
and universities came
to decide that they would
undertake a major change,
which is to say, the
admission of women.
And it's about how
complicated it is to engage
in institutional change.
So I look at the
role of leadership
I look at the role of
process and planning.
And there's quite
a lot of difference
among institutions
and the extent
to which process matters.
At Princeton, process
mattered hugely,
very careful planning
and analysis.
Bill was an
extraordinary leader.
When he was invited
by Bob Goheen
to become the first full-time
provost of the university,
he said it was clear
to him, to Bill,
that Princeton
needed to go co-ed,
to remain an institution
of the highest quality.
And that it would be unable to
continue to attract first-rate
students and faculty
if it didn't.
I think that for women
and men, going to school
together enriches the
intellectual experience.
You do have different
perspectives in the classroom
when you have men
and women together.
And you do learn about the way
other people see the world when
you have those perspectives.
It's true when you have
students of different racial,
and ethnic, and economic
backgrounds as well.
You learn more when the
people you're talking with
are not all the same as you are.
Outside the classroom,
participating
in extracurricular
activities together
enlarges your sense
of who makes things
happen, how leadership works,
enlarges your respect for people
who are different than you are.
So I think it -- I think
it's a good thing.